actors really enunciate their words
we had a good time just you and i huh we
did man you guys had the fourth down
daddy was gone daddy was daddy was down
with some no no we've got a few emails
complaining about your sports knowledge
uh tyra kill he thought he played for
arizona and he was a db yeah now
hey he's the one who said it i didn't
say that sure
yeah yeah yeah he said it yeah new rule
when daddy's gone yeah
we don't talk sports no no football no
no sports in general i don't want yeah
you know
it's too bad you're not around when i'm
breaking down fighting oh no
and now you didn't bring down any fights
and i'm physically
physically getting up and showing people
stuff like i would have well and then
when i go like this this is this is my
favorite [ __ ] to do and i i do it when
only people who don't know fighting i go
now you see how he's winning that corner
see how his but his foot is stepping
around his foot you always want it i'd
physically throw up
i know yeah you try to yeah you people
kick mine when i say stuff like this i
go i go it's not the punching it's where
you're punching from sure so watch how
and they eat it up though they eat it
the [ __ ] up well i know my [ __ ] then
compared to them you're bruce lee and a
lot of people think i'm a black belt and
should get you because what happens is
people go
uh i knew it was you i was looking for
the cloudflare here but uh and i was
like thank you and i go i go well it's a
little bit here from from wrestling
it's a little bit there
who who was like people really think
you're a black belt no not many well
have a black belt in taekwondo now that
never happened hey hey great we had a
we had you ruined it with the sport talk
listen hey who was i with the i was at
though at the improv the other night
i forget what comic it was and he goes
oh there's dalia he goes dude your ears
are still like that i go what literally
before i go on stage i had to bring him
up right before i go on he goes you're
here your ears you still keep your ears
like that yeah
i keep them that way yeah what would i
do dude goes well can't you just [ __ ]
change it back once you stop like then
they go down and go god damn no dude
there's nothing i can do i said i guess
i could have a surgery like
scrape it out like a major surgery
speaking of scraping i said is it that
big of a deal he was kind of so so
speaking of scraping things out i went
to the dentist this morning now i don't
know about you i'm not a i'm not a big
dentist goer you understand like i never
go to the dentist
unless unless something breaks
yeah so level five two so she looked at
my charge she goes
2018 was the last time you had a
screening i go oh a cleaning i go yeah
she does that oh my god
she she goes that's two she kept
checking it to make sure she goes you're
sure i go no i just don't come and they
had to get in there and give me you guys
don't go to the dentist no yeah we're
both pretty no here's my thing is uh
this is my thing this is our thing right
i don't like the dentist i went in 2014
she goes and i didn't go
several years before that she goes oh
wow she goes now i don't take this the
wrong way but you for teeth you're very
gifted like for you not going and soon i
went oh you [ __ ] up i'm never coming
back because i i haven't been in 10
years she said the same told me every
time i would get the same because you
have
such healthy gums
that's all i got to hear say less [ __ ]
now i'm not coming coming in really now
here's the freaking girl i freak out i
have to go really yeah i have to get a
cleaning i have to do i have to i have
to that's smart i can't not go to the
dentist yeah that's crazy that you all
do that oh six years seven years seven
hours i get that beat mine 10 15. but
the thing is
you know my girl goes and takes the kids
like monthly and she goes once you got
here now i got something this morning
she goes what do you have stuff i never
go but the thing is
is but now daddy i think has two
cavities up top here
in the bottom tops and bottoms i promise
but you know what though you know what
though i've had sugar in three weeks
because of it because because it hurts
so bad if i eat sugar my teeth hurt so
bad oh you guys went i'm not getting
sugar anymore your boy's losing weight
that's good my girl goes you have
cavities clearly i go i do but daddy's
not eating sugar anymore this is so it's
frozen now here's the thing about that
it only gets worse and it'll get right
into the bone so what we have to do
you get a root canal
that you don't want you don't want one
so we got to make it we're going to get
this root canals can be bad for your
heart believe it or not some of that
stuff could be bad yes but bacteria
i've had a root canal handled it pretty
funny yeah you want to be careful
with that i'm gonna roll the dice with
it because the thing i'm losing weight i
haven't touched sugar my body is
re
i cannot see sugar without being like oh
get it because it hurts your teeth yeah
so my body's like oh so when you eat you
know me i love sugar oh yeah so if you
eat sugar it hurts i'm a sugar baby when
you drink water
no
and that's i told my guy i said i'm only
gonna make a change if when i start
eating like regular food it starts
hurting till then
it's yeah wrong wheels fall off well
daddy i get gold friends before i do a
root canal well he looked at me and goes
now now you got some cracks you know
you're two the two back teeth are just
you grind your teeth sixty yeah i'm like
yeah fifty yeah
fifty four fifty four yeah but you know
so you got barnacles on your foot i warm
them i wear my teeth hard yeah oh yeah
these chompers been through some [ __ ]
yeah now you guys grew up in the united
states where you had fluoride in the
water system i grew up overseas where
there was no fluoride so what happened
believe it or not
is that your teeth just they can
you lost all their teeth before they
were
my grandma you know she grew up in
england and she was around the days when
there was just no dentistry they didn't
give a [ __ ] so she lost her teeth she
said lost all her teeth at like 18. yeah
she said like what yeah like since 18.
yeah that was very common in most of the
world you'd see people who just lost
their like a whole row of teeth you just
pull up teeth you don't have any wisdom
teeth i don't think so i think they got
i do and that's why my teeth are slowly
like making a v
does it does it hurt no because that's
what happened to me like mine were like
pushing and it like would hurt a little
bit
uh when i was like 26 is when it really
started to pop and i had to get them out
i got them out see my mind making my
teeth like push to the front like a
travis scott concert yes smile give them
show them the show
there's a real a lot of serious uneven
no my bottom teeth are like an english
bulldog yeah but your front teeth are
not winning any awards bubba compared to
yours they're not winning yourself
stick with it and so they looked at my
teeth and they went because look at this
dude do you remember when you would come
in with invisalign and you'd be like
how's everybody's shakes on i'm like
well you can't can you take those out
you remember that
he's like what's that funny because this
is i mean
this weekend come see me
then
sorry everybody bill bill burr was uh
going on stage and he had his invisalign
and he goes i'm just gonna [ __ ] go on
i go you're gonna go perform like that
no way no way i'd have to take it off
plus i was doing the goldbergs so i'd
have to take it off i could never wear
it you have to wear it all day i'm going
to wear it at night you got to do it all
of it and i'd be like [ __ ] all this it
would hurt
don't just get braces then i've already
said that i might go that'll break
breakfast i might go back to invisalign
[ __ ] it go no go to braces because
braces work the best you can you never
take them off yeah no hey is there
anything more depressing than a guy over
40 with metal braces oh my god ain't
nothing wrong with that better be a life
coach serial killer
because they want straight teeth if you
ask me if a grown man comes at me with
braces those those ones you wear in
middle school i'm rolling my window up
and locking my door and driving away and
they have the rubber bands on them
it's
i just brought this because i don't like
carrying all this crap oh okay in the
world but um yeah i got to pump it up
i'll do it for you guys you you bounce
back from that food poisoning right
quick that's a good thing about food
poisoning you lose some weight now daddy
was on death's doorstep
about two in the morning i might have to
go to the emergency room that bad ooh
yeah you know when you're throwing up
and it's just like that dry hurl and
you're just throwing up bile at that
point yeah
that's it yeah he's on death doorstep
that's that [ __ ] bacteria i get that
iv and fully redeemed myself that's that
aquatic
bacteria oh then the iv felt great you
could just feel it that was nice i just
hate when the iv guy talks to you it's
like hey i don't do a podcast you know
yeah well my mom but ivy and get going
my mother got super sick and almost died
once and i said what happened because i
had food poisoning once i said what'd
you do well she was in sicily and
thought it was a good idea and sicily
there was to take the muscles
she's in the water smart with a lemon
from the water she's in the water with a
lemon
and what you do is you take the muscles
you shuck them on the rocks
in the seat of the life and you eat them
oh that's what she did is your mom and
daughter and she would say your mom
i'm going to ask again apparently my
mother apparently she thought she was
snotter you might think she thought she
was snotter and she was eating you must
do
raw muscles
now hold on
careful now
not careful now that was the stupid
thing to do
she took a loaf of bread down there by
the oats rocking back and forth look at
you
see people eating what
holy [ __ ] chin you don't need this dude
i do need it he says he does need it i
love that you're doing it does it help
tin yeah i think it's actually helping a
little bit yeah yeah does it
it raises your neck up poor guy it
actually pushes your head up so yeah
yeah it pulls it's called the traction
oh dude i would like to take that did
you see the meme that that chase dude
made of you no
it was all the rings yeah
i like the african ladies yeah you know
what's talking about yeah
now what doctor recommended the severe
neck braces not the doctors it's people
that say that you should try this before
surgery
oh oh so the internet told you to do
this yeah
wait more of the doctors doctors want me
to do surgery so bad yeah the way they
were doing it too was like
i love the way he
forever the answer is forever i think i
have to it's like maybe you gotta do it
for three years maybe more now but then
later on i could do it less maybe just
do it when you record a good idea
actually yeah i mean because i'm not
doing i'm just yeah i'm here around here
girl
yeah man how many times a day do you do
it could there be anything less
sometimes a few times a day
i know it's not sexy dude come on man
i'd rather be healthy than you know oh
yeah dude health count okay what are we
looking at right
look up look up people eating muscles
raw muscles in in the water yeah dude
yeah bro people from those regions do
that because that's what they do because
they can't have they don't have money to
buy tomatoes don't do eating raw mussels
in the water don't do that
it doesn't make sense
yeah like these guys are yeah there you
go that's kind of sad
hey b 2021 thank god mental health is
finally a thing because so you know this
doing the pandemic everything's crazy
right now tactics and anxiety
so many people are struggling right now
and they're not feeling like their
normal self also guys tend to not
they tend to think of mental health as
sort of a weakness yeah yeah and and and
that's what's great about it being
online so you gotta talk about it yeah
dude more we talk about the more
normalized and that's where better
health comes in and dude
therapy helps it do that's the bottom
line therapy helps it doesn't have to be
sitting around talking about your
feelings so what is therapy exactly it's
whatever you want it to be man you talk
privately all right you talk to a
professional that you know you're
talking to your friends family talk to a
person who knows what's going on
relationship issues stress we're talking
about professional online counseling all
right
you can talk on the phone video live
chat sessions
you can literally have video phone it's
like somebody's in the room with you
dude join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about see
if it's for you because you are your
greatest asset and in 48 hours you can
be communicating with a therapist ty i
swear bite man and this podcast firing
the kid is brought to you by better help
all right and you guys get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com fighter
that's
betterhelp.com oh my god dude you know
what i sometimes i can't sleep at night
and i think myself how does lebron james
come
it really it's called it's called the
app calm if you want somebody to read
you a bedtime story if you want to hear
nature you want to hear me meditation
meditation it quiets your brain i have
it on my phone i use it all the time my
girl uses it all the time it's about
it's all about mental fitness dude can
help you train your brain so you sleep
better reduce stress perform at your
best just like the king james yeah it's
the number one app for sleep and
meditation dude it's great so if you
head to calm.com.calm.com
fighter for a limited time you get 40
off a calm premium subscription all
right again for limited time the fine
kid listeners can join the likes of
lebron james in using calm get 40
off all right a calm premium
subscription at the time sleep dude if
you don't take care of your sleep then
you that's we're not even out of the
blocks you got to be sleeping sleep so
it's everything i sleep like a baby
thanks to calm get started calm.com
slash fighter that c-a-l-m-com
fighter are you talking about the
barefoot kids you have nothing else to
eat yeah oh they dive down there and get
there but you can eat some raw stuff if
you know your mom can't if you come from
the sea and you and you know how to do
that stuff
look they're dipping it
okay good mom can't do that dude no she
got chumps i bet they are delicious if
your stomach can you know it's like
mexicans drinking the mexican water but
also if you know what muscles you got to
know certain [ __ ] what time caller
yeah you're in sicily
you might go to a restaurant mama kelly
yeah
don't be she want to be one with the
people she's a talented shedder pants
she's still here bro i was so sick trash
can here on the [ __ ] i was like a
bang bro girl dude double penetration is
that right double really double getting
the devil out of your body dude that's
what it does
it's i just do though hold it down for
24 hours daddy we're gonna make it
through him yeah yeah you knew yeah did
the doctor you know i showed up put an
iv in yeah but they they put all sorts
of like they give you stuff for pain
electrolytes yeah they've given you
nausea yeah they give you nausea
medicine they give you painkillers i'm
like dude how's this going come on daddy
really hype that thing i got a lot of
stuff running through my system anyway
go ahead now you cleaned yourself out
though probably no nicotine you didn't
do anything excuse me yeah woman addict
so you gotta have nicotine even when you
have food poisoning oh yeah you don't
even
every morning
i'm throwing up anyways dude that's
impressive as hell you know what this
would be like really the first coffee
i've had in a long time because coffee
or like certain food like i can't eat
sweat thanks dog thanks meatball i can't
have like real spicy foods right now
yeah what do you got in that cup this is
whiskey so whatever you have in your
stomach i'm told whiskey will burn it
especially is that true yeah tiger thick
cures all illness is that what they say
well whiskey by the way when you're in
it it doesn't matter
you're in a country where the water and
parasites you you want to get you want
to get some whiskey in your tummy or
some just some spirits so i would have
to if i was in that situation i would
have to do whiskey
yeah whatever yeah i have to relax well
unless you want to [ __ ] your pants i
always drink hard liquor if i have if
there's ice in my drink or whatever i'll
do a shot oh for sure because it'll
equal it out right what do you mean a
lot of times kill that bacteria oh dude
you know what i want to talk about i
want to talk about on monday
you got another kid coming this world i
got another kid coming in this world now
and i'm coming up with names now now
casey
well you know my boy casey who i love i
was thinking about
some devil yeah and your sons will be
smaller
mason's gonna be small your son's gonna
be smaller let's think of small names
chip
no chip dude little chip
chip you know a little chip
a little chip dude a little chip hey
little little chip come about football
no because can i explain rudy hold on
rudy
her family the men and her family big
boys and that's fine yeah
i didn't my dad big boy your dad's huge
bigger than me so you think your son's
gonna be a big boy well i got big you
actually have big jeans i take after
mommy though five two your mom's tiny
and so your sister's pretty small too uh
no well i guess for a girl she's like
you're about the same size what does
this change big girl
dwarf names oh wow
wow
i just noticed
we might find something no but you know
you know what though you know when
people like oh the baby's small that you
know like boston wasn't a big baby tiger
was a big baby yeah it's the like when
they get to a year that's when you kind
of know yeah so everyone's like oh my
god that baby was 12 pounds eight ounces
none of that [ __ ] matters no it matters
like it's not six months into it if
they're still tiny ankle biter
rug rat okay
little ankle biter bambino no what are
you thinking hair bambino are we like
brendan even in the conversation have
you ever met another brand the problem
with brendan is people call him brandon
well no dude that's why i'm trying to
get more famous
name another famous brendan britney
fraser brendan frazier okay
um playing a lot of weight dude listen i
love brendan fraser
yeah take it easy so there was brendan
shanahan captain of the detroit red
wings he retired
name another one bro not a lot of
brendan
type and famous british brandon lemieux
plays for the los angeles kings is his
dad mario lumiere uh claude o'neill
there you go
famous
yeah brandon uh brennan is that no
brother you didn't even think about it
dude well it's brendan then you can't
brand no your brand little brand
little brand uncle your uncle brendan
big brendan's here i don't like it okay
that's fine but i don't like brian hey
that's that's you and you want you are
you thinking like
are we thinking like unique names like
trying to go down my lane well i'm
trying to go try and go tiger boston
where it's very different
honestly we're trying to go normal i
like we want jeff dave i want frank
not dave joe no i don't like those billy
nope billy's not bad billy's good i like
billy i like she's small i like billy
you like casey not gonna be small i like
jack i like billy i like you know what i
like jack i like jack i like jack it's a
strong it's a strong name it's a richard
you know what it is it's original it's
american i know it's american and we
need that right jack callan dude what's
up just like blue hey i like blue i like
blue light your friend's blue and he's a
badass i know he looks weird though
let's be honest but he's a badass yeah
he looks weird though blue
blue eyes i call him blue karate count
blue karate count why you got it why you
gotta add karate
spitballing ideas here yeah we want to
get america back on the right track blue
jack tucker
tucker not a bad name
tucker carlson okay
all right hannity
hannity jack allen hannah's strong name
no no i'm not doing that all right you
know what he wanted him i figured
actually i do i got fox the phone
the front runner is jack no
runner from the name is blue kamala
and yeah yeah jack is jack is strong
jack's strong i like my son's name is
finn jack i like those like simple names
man i was gonna name my son gus but
that's just a shitty name because you
can't be a hero when you're god yeah you
can yeah maybe he might make him break
the cycle
is your son i don't like his son he's a
little young has he have you had to sit
through any of his performances do they
have like has he done a play no not yet
no no players john had an improv he did
an improv show
at 10 and uh that's that's at 10 for
sure yeah he kept looking over was it
long
i know that's what they do dude
dude he knows my dad's a celebrity yeah
my father he's a comedian
they want the okay
the kids are all there i'm like
keep it down well you know i sent you
that video when you call me videos
tigers getting promoted in jiu jitsu to
a grey belt which is a big deal yeah for
him especially he's not gonna do it too
long dude he was
russian [ __ ] tossing these kids on
their head and the coach was like dude i
don't know where you're teaching
techniques i went i swear to you he's
i've never taught him that that's not my
just he watches ufc with me he's
i'm hip tossing cool wow dude 10 year
old game jesus yeah why did you not want
to teach him
it's just a lot for a five-year-old yeah
yeah it's dangerous got it so he's
tossing the kids on their heads and
she'll teach her
oh for sure but i teach him stuff now
but um
but so they'll do a thing like whoever
gets the 10 takedowns first and so tiger
knows if he gets 10 takedowns he gets
ice cream after since i said dude if you
get 10 takedowns you get taken down you
eat ice cream he's got an ice cream
every single night since we made that
deal every single night he goes dad we
get an ice cream here's the problem
though let's take the kid down look at
me go one like
my son kept running around he kept me
i'm like sitting there watching the kids
and i just get a tap on my shoulder he
goes i'm pretty funny what you what was
you what was your favorite part yeah go
back you fired me ball
sorry but yeah tiger keep looking i'll
go dude [ __ ] [ __ ] pay attention dude
quit looking over here that you're doing
no more than him yeah huh you can
already see
he's been riding the skateboard ryan's
skateboarding yeah we got to get him a
new one yeah i'm getting one for
christmas okay
hopefully not listen to the show my
first reaction any time i see a big dude
my first reaction is muscular i go
professional athlete and then you go no
not necessarily at all no no no no and
then the reason i know this is what's to
it no but also because if you watch hard
knocks and you watch all those huge
really muscular guys and one percent
make it among those guys you're like oh
that's why yeah it's [ __ ] well like
like my boy will compton for he does
bust one of the boys into a football
campaign with him oh yeah but for i
think for the national championship
hopefully i didn't say that before we
agreed to it anyways but will compton
you're talking stuff
all big 12 university of nebraska
linebacker stud yeah dude he's you know
he just signed with the raiders
he like floats around dude oh yeah like
was tennessee for a while floats around
he's on splash team what do you talk
about talent dude and you're talking
like smart
smart monster he's not big compared to a
lot of those guys he's big but no he's
like a big boy he's not small he's
perfect he's perfect for linebacker yeah
because speed now remember you got to
cover so if you're playing the chiefs
you also got to know your [ __ ] you got
to be smart you're smart but here's the
thing
so the nfl is so [ __ ] dicey
he could start for any team in the
league it's just about opportunity the
right fit the right system but until he
gets his
shot you're bouncing around dude yeah
these are the people that you you know
who you're competing with
oh dude and you're talking all-star dude
like if you went to college football
right now he'd win the buckets award is
that true that's true super stunt so if
you put him in the in the pro in a
college lineup excuse me
he would have 40 tackles in the against
alabama why is that because he can read
the offenses and just is ahead of these
guys he's just got so much experience
pattern recognition he's been playing
since he was [ __ ] six like i did he's
he's a he's a monster
by the way and by the way
steal your girl a looker a look yeah
he's a dime piece girl yeah super duper
of course he does well of course he does
but just as stunning he's like bouncing
around great guy he's one of the few
guys in the nfl you know there's a lot
of guys trying to podcast now you know
athletes try podcasting he's good dude i
did his podcast all right
happy holidays merry christmas
merry christmas i just know now i feel
awkward yeah okay
that's a great picture
hey why'd you like it with my profile
dog
popped up oh i see what you did
i like that it still makes you feel
awkward cat yeah with just us or just i
think in general like anytime someone
points out something i'm doing ever
since i was a kid like it it made me
intentional you know attention like
makes me feel embarrassed almost because
they come from a big family so like when
someone gets singles out it's usually
like they're getting clowned everybody
knows like you're just like ah and now
you make a living off doing it yeah it's
weird huh it's very weird very weird i'm
gonna start i'm gonna be good at it i'm
gonna post
that you go to will compton's pick
i think will's expecting a baby right
now too
dude you're talking about just a beast
dude oh you did this part of nashville
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so he's back on the raiders i go
dude i need a jersey because you still
have the jersey last time yeah but he's
number 57. hardest that i've taken in
the afl let me see that you gotta lit up
for what
hit on a football field the hardest i
would say
oh you know what
outside of like getting blindsided and
like getting the air knocked out here or
something like that probably against the
new orleans saints i posted a video on
this like a year ago too going against
the new orleans saints when i was on the
washington redskins i was taking off and
tried
just throwing my body into this dude and
i mean i went stiff like taking a metal
bat oh dude
did he say night night oh he said he
goes so i was running right
that's
yeah and
obviously he smokes me and the dude's
like over 300 pounds just built like a
brick [ __ ] house
and i'm like you know i like go stiff
and down to the ground and he's like
night night [ __ ]
there you go that's a lot of fun damn
him and his boy taylor man they're
beasts though but they're kind of the
first guy in the nfl to do this yep but
he has the personality for it yes he
does
i i find that a lot of players because
their team players have real a lot of
social intelligence they're the funnest
to hang out with they really are for
sure football players yeah that i find
their personalities the most to be the
most some of them are introverted but a
lot of them because you're around so
many different persons parents fighters
night and day but remember if you're
playing at university of nebraska you're
playing with guys from california
compton yes you're playing from texas
fifth ward you're playing from day count
different races different yeah and you
all have to come together like the
[ __ ] you know the uh titans what was
that do you remember the time
you all got to come together and gel as
a team that speak chemistry yep so those
guys
verbal iqs and like social awareness is
so high because this girl's a superhero
oh wow
yeah that's awesome oh it's a girl
good for him man good for him man man we
should spit ball names for his kid
um
yeah well just kids bringing me a well
it's good it's gonna be a girl girls are
tough call her athleta let's see i like
so if if i had a girl i like boy names
for girls oh like a dr like charlie
charlie i don't give away the name
because we do have a girl i'm for sure
naming this i met a girl named cody yeah
i love i love you
i like cody for a boy or a girl cody's
not a bad name for my boy but how many
old codies do you know i know too many
cody's
how about do you want him to work at
chipotle how about toby
colby yeah but then anyone can call him
cody if you don't like brendan yeah
because of brandon cody also [ __ ]
cody
i like jack right to me blue blue it's
unique dude i'm right with you on that
like why would you give i don't get like
he was crazy i can't believe you named
your kid tiger and boston yeah [ __ ]
because i don't want to just gel in with
everybody else
i want him to have that different name
so he he's different i'm calling him
blue
[ __ ] yeah blue cows how are you going to
spell it good name just regular i mean
to be cheeky l-u
or
o-o-o could be stupid but but no we're
calling blow that yeah the only problem
is you got to speak
do you see you always gotta remember
yeah
he's gonna be bullied yeah guys gonna
[ __ ] with i don't care who you are my
kid's up [ __ ] yeah you're gonna get
shaq of elementary he still gets bullied
yeah 100 yeah you punch kids in the face
whatever yeah but they're going to get
bullied yes so if you remember names
you'll remember yeah you call them
gumblow
tough day on the yard
so b-l-u-e probably just keep
your girl going to yeah for it she likes
it
wow
she was playing with parker
kaden
i just parker parker sounds too parker
feels like a real estate agent in orange
county i agree man parker cowan here
parker like the house hey guys parker
parker how many cool parker's no parker
town is a life coach we don't want that
for him we want more for blue yeah it's
blue i'm gonna call him blue for now
here in columbus here's the thing bubba
yeah name him jack
parker blue i call him blue that's right
uncle uncle brendan calls him blue uncle
brown's calling blue now i know he comes
over until brent's house no you're gonna
leave
yeah you're gonna love my house hate
yours i know because you got all the boy
stuff all the stuff you got all this
stuff we have a basketball court
pool slides you got trampolines cars got
a trampoline oh jesus oh yeah you do
have a trampoline oh yeah i saw it yeah
it's disneyland so it's a [ __ ]
disneyland yeah disaster that's one of
my kids in the pandemics complaining
like you [ __ ] ignorant little bastard
yeah you have any idea if i was in a
pandemic when i was your age we didn't
have
[ __ ] to do
we had nothing well it's like my
daughter i had my brother that's it he
was terrible when your daughter turns 13
uh what happens is uh there's something
in their dna that's like they they take
my day oh yeah and uh and i'll be like
i'll be like i'm i'm you know she had an
audition she had an audition i said for
the school play and i go i
i can help you with this she goes no
thanks dad oh wow and i go i bet you i
went i went oh okay wow i go so again
she goes no i got this and by the way
it's it's a theater thing and she's like
this place okay oh because dad's i'm
doing theater because i don't know
anything about theater i don't know do
you take a warm hand well my joke is
this and she's also like she's learning
things i forgot about in school
so she'll do stuff like she'll be like
you don't you don't know all the layers
of the atmosphere
i'll push a pie in your face yeah it's
like i did when i was seven [ __ ] like i
wouldn't hit her but i'll push a pie
i'll twist it in just a little bit there
you go i don't believe in hitting kids
well i will give him a a strong c on the
elbow strong oh yeah
oh by the way i'll do that i'll do that
to my boy he'll feel the power all right
my boy i feel the power my boy's
fighting with my my daughter on the
plane and making a big scene
and fighting over who gets the window
seat and i got into
fisticuff and my son was initiating it
and i grabbed your daughter beat the
shot yeah she'll be they should she [ __ ]
around but she's she's that's her little
brother long and big yes and she can she
can play some
tennis yeah i grabbed him sonny's got
the body on her i grabbed i grabbed him
and i went and i do the same thing i'll
i'll see clamp hole
well you'll do that to a grown man
i had to do it to a grown man who we're
very close with yeah because he got out
of line and you had you had to see clamp
in front of jamie at the laugh factory
yeah it was very embarrassing and you
had to see clamp and it really
everyone views me you see cleveland's a
grown ass man sure did he really imagine
here's the thing you can't he's too
comfortable he can really embarrass me
in front of you you can't get in it you
can't physically accost him so if you're
going to physically this guy was used to
doing he was treating other people
really shitty okay and i knew that and
he did it to me
you can't do that i mean you just you
can't get physical i see clamped them so
[ __ ] hard
you can't get physical with the bear
yeah you can get in i've gotten in your
face i've been i've been i've done this
yelled at each other yeah i've been i've
been you know i walk off like i'm i'm
i'm pissed off you got into his face
yeah i got my well i mean not in his
face but i get i have yelled at i have
flash but he's the same way we get all
angry but for two seconds yeah of course
i mean honestly it's like donald trump
it's real quick yeah but i'm macho i get
macho i've been around for years like
like one time we were brothers we had to
shoot some [ __ ] and i go i'm not doing
this [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] not doing it
and i walk off and you go then i'll do
it dude and i'm walking like like i'm
ready to fight somebody
but i'm not going to
even if my weather i'm not going to get
up you got the wall go like this i'm not
going to go douche i'm not going to put
hands on him
i'm not going to put hands on you
because you just have that aggression
naturally it's insane yeah but
you just you just need to know
your boundaries yeah pikachu don't be
stupid now don't be stupid god i'm so
excited for your sun blue blue blue yeah
dude get a blue tattoo and i'll just
show up and just go there you go oh dude
give him a meal
i'll buy your kid you'll raise him
yeah how much
300 how much maybe 10 grand for that kid
hey your kids worth 10 grand hey
are you genetically i am athletic
my girl's very athletic it's true all
right might be a little beast he i think
he's going to be athletic i think your
daughter's the most athletic but i think
but daddy's coordinating he might be
give me that in my i'm pretty sure no
you're dude for average joe you're a
beast i'm pretty cool yeah for sure so
girl my girly girl's coordinated i know
you know he could be a little outlier
he could be a little i think it's gonna
be good if he is small though that chip
on his shoulder yeah do you like that
rudy syndrome going my buddies my
buddy's kids his wife is 411 and he's
five seven and his kids are
his kids came home one was 11 the other
was like
uh 13
and and they go dead the son goes dad
i'm small
i mean i they no he goes dad kids are
calling me small man they're calling me
small yeah it's tough and he he and and
and i guess some of the he in a part of
the world where some of the kids are
samoan and tongan yeah and he goes um he
was in utah so a lot of tongans so much
more they get yes
so that's who you're [ __ ] with right
those kids on the playground those
tongan simones and he goes he comes on
his dad the kid calling me small
compared and my friend my friend goes
that's because
you oh
how old is he he was 13 years old don't
you own it though own it he goes that's
what he's saying because that's true
and you're good yeah yeah depends dude
there's small guys who crush it like
what dude you're north star if you're in
the sports could be like wes welker or
there's like messy stuff sports ain't
dude look at fighting there's a bunch of
smaller dudes yes
i mean there's so many small guys so
many small guys you just crush it yeah i
do think being big is easier in life
don't you find i don't over everybody i
feel like both have their advantages
i feel not a lot of bands are small
yeah
i mean you got to work harder i guess
yeah that everything yeah yeah
cheaper clothes
there that is a good advantage my shoes
i don't have to spend that much money on
because i'm short and my feet are small
so i get i'd see i forgot i don't know
i forgot you guys were not tall i just
forgot that appreciate that yeah i'm
glad you don't see height you know you
don't see how he don't see color you
know i mean i don't think it matters i
don't think of you guys as i don't it's
kind of
very well adjusted yeah yeah are you
taller than both of them okay in my head
i am i don't think i actually am but in
my head i think i think cat's taller we
stand up
you guys are still in frame too pretty
barely
he's well taller
you guys are not tall guys
nobody over here is tall you guys don't
have small man like energy though wait
how tall is your how tall is your dead
meatball
your dad's 5 10. yeah meatballs like a
little pit bull yeah yeah yeah okay i
used to be that you'd want him in your
foxhole yeah
he's a digger yeah he digs
he'll fight and dig up that rump yeah
yeah now you're you have a lot of size
but you have uh you don't move slow see
a lot of guys who are big move slow and
they and they tend to be they apologize
for their size by being clumsy and super
sweet and through passive well we were
doing the same
you got no no no you're very nice but
you have you have a um
you have a weird thing you have also a
good chip on your shoulder so it makes
you yeah it makes you uh
it's not a napoleon complex
but you move at a clip yeah you move at
a class that's what i'm saying when we
were doing those sled pushes and the
burpees that's right this [ __ ]
was just i don't know i don't know he'll
compete he was quick no if there's if
there's a competition
we were playing he and we were playing
uh uh volleyball in the beach and we
didn't know we had just gotten to become
friends we were friends for a year
and this guy this galaxy i can't believe
he got you to play volleyball this life
coach is this woman goes
uh oh i know you're dominating she goes
you're a pro athlete comedian she she
goes we can say her name
yeah like eliza
i love her i love it but elizabeth eliza
is such a smile she goes she goes man i
thought you'd be better you're a pro
athlete i thought you'd be better at
volleyball so i see brennan i see
brandon he was young oh he was young and
still fighting so if you're still
fighting he had that thing so i just see
him like this i held on everybody his
[ __ ] his [ __ ]
patience humor no humor he went like
this he was when he saw him stand and
his mouth opened a little he went like
this like in his right behind his face
he went
like that but it said he went like this
his breathing segment
and then he turns to tony is his coach
who's a who's a bronze medal he's
telling jeffrey's bronze medal in the
olympics boxing yep and goes uh box and
bernard and he goes like this he looks
and tony gets really competitive and he
goes like he goes we have to win yeah
yeah we have to win so i spiked it like
meet the parents on the [ __ ] face
you did yeah you're trouble
you pulled that michael jordan you took
that person yeah they took it personally
and it funny how that how when you're
young that [ __ ] can get to you so deeply
tiger has the same thing though because
they were doing something and again he
shouldn't be talking to his grandma like
this was just that kobe mentality that
he has did when something his grandma
goes
uh who he loves dearly he probably loves
him or anybody in this world and they're
playing outside and she goes oh you lost
she goes you lost and kept going you
lost you lost seniors you're a loser and
grabs the ball and [ __ ] poof i'm like
well [ __ ] yeah that's good
let me talk to you dude yeah so i tore
him like you can't call your grandma
loser yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you dude yeah but inside i'm like yeah
we need that there's no losers around
here my son is is spiked up on it he's
an amazing actor like my son uh i get a
call i gotta come to the podcast the
other monday i gotta come to the podcast
uh i get a call from my ex she goes you
have to pick finn up um i'm not in town
and he's sick he's sick i go what he
goes he's not feeling well jesus christ
all right so he's got a stomach thing so
i got to get i got to go get him then
drive him back to his house and then
come the podcast so i'll be 15 minutes
late
so but it's out of my way i got i got to
drive
santa monica and i pull up it's 40
minutes you know and i've all i got my
routine i'm going to do my now you got
to get get your clothes going kids
[ __ ]
i get there
and he comes up bouncing out
hey dad i'm bouncing he felt fine and i
go
huh that you're sick i thought you were
sick because no i am i am i go are you
are you now what um what's going on with
where he goes my stomach it's uh it's a
whirlpool it's going like this a lot
like when i go
with a clip energy like that look at
that i look at the uh nuts at the
[ __ ] principle i go and she goes yeah
she probably should need a better
breakfast she just walks out yeah she
knows what's up all right they've seen
it i get it i go i go i facetime mom and
i say uh yeah yeah finn's uh i got him
he's sick and i go and she goes do we
have a little faker on her hands yeah
and he goes faker faker i'm not talking
either one of you guys i'm not somebody
you guys don't believe me i'm done and
he just turns and he faces the window
like that he's like that and i go oh
geez all right well he seems to have a
lot of energy he's super mad i better
get out of here because i got to see
what's wrong with him he definitely
doesn't feel well he's super angry like
that so i just we're driving and i go i
go so um
so tell me
you're you stick with a scale of one to
ten he's like what i got one being
terrible sev ten being amazing whatever
you guys
like a six i go that's pretty good seven
yeah because right now maybe
good good good so you're feeling better
that's good i say now you know that i'm
i'm trained in reading human behavior
yeah and he goes what do you mean i go
well i can read someone's face you give
yourself away you know what ticks are no
i go you use ticks you do little things
with your face they tell me that you're
lying i go now if i look in the face i
can always tell i'm very good so he just
goes like this he just goes
and i go okay now tell me the story what
happened he was laughing i was no no it
was great he goes he goes i was i was
there was a very long essay use the word
essay teacher was
doing this long essay and i began felt
really sick and i was i had a fever and
i just said i don't feel sick i gotta go
to the nursery i mean to the nurse and i
go okay stop stop tell me the same story
again because you know you gotta if
you're lying yeah yeah same story yep
i can just see he's frowning his tell me
something i go stop stop i believe you
and he goes
thanks dad oh that's cool no and i go i
go you're welcome he goes thanks for
believing me you're lying i go
you got it and i see him
and he turns to the window but he
doesn't know that i can see his
reflections
and this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
it's going like this he's going
i love it he's raising his eyebrows that
stuff doesn't bother me though and i go
i go you i go you gave yourself away
yeah you had me and you're celebrating
in the mirror i can't see you that stuff
doesn't bother me though but here
he goes i was born i used to fake being
sick i remember my body made such a big
deal doesn't bother me either who gives
a [ __ ] he also got away one day
one [ __ ] my dad made such a big deal
of it i said the lesson here is you
can't celebrate that early dude you got
me you won well done well done don't
don't abuse it but you were celebrating
too i'll tell you what's different
though is i like i hate i didn't like
school i didn't want to go tiger he was
sick the other day and he woke up like
how you feel it's great excellent
actually i go good enough for school
years oh yeah i'm like [ __ ] dude i would
have melted this thing to [ __ ] he was
ready he loves school he just loves
school i love school which is well i
can't wait to have kids yeah it's it's
papa mail doug it's good it's good oh
did you show count your new tattoo no
not yet sure i'm not gonna show you why
it was a surprise well you used the vlog
where's the vlog now hold on thursday
now see now oh it's a surprise for
everybody don't don't worry about
surprises because thursday yeah you
don't care no yeah you don't care about
my tattoos yeah it's not like you don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah
a it's a giant it's giant lettering
across the stomach oh it must have hurt
and what what's the lettering what's the
lettering then that gives away if it's
oasis i'm going to lose my [ __ ] mind
i already have an oasis tattoo so thank
you a bunch of them yeah it's a punk
rock thing right yeah is it a band
uh one of my favorite bands fugazi or
something uh uh no no okay name of
fugazi i see you it's cause you see me
wear the shirts
yeah i like what you're about to get
though that'd be cool all right hey who
uh what's his who's the lead singer of
um
of what
oh god um
dave grohl yeah no no no no no no i'm
sorry yeah not dave i'm not i'm thinking
of someone else tony hawk was on uh
flagrant with
and he's talking about you know how your
when your kids doing acting you
obviously could help them out he says
that his kids are into skateboarding and
the friends will come over and be like
oh look at this [ __ ] and tony he'll come
in from like skateboarding and like oh
what are you guys looking at like oh you
don't understand this he's like who do
you think created that move
the kid's like dad get out of here he's
like right and then he goes upstairs
isn't that amazing not weird my daughter
would not even entertain me helping her
yeah they just don't i'm like i can help
you with this if there's anything i can
help you you see the rocks a little girl
you see the rock's little girl she's
cute as [ __ ] and she doesn't believe
that her dad's the voice of moana and
he's like you're welcome she's like you
sound just like him he's like
i'm i'm moana and she's like no you're
not and he's like yeah yeah i am he
keeps he's doing the voice exactly she
goes that's really good but you're not
him and he's like [ __ ] what he the
[ __ ] that's amazing crazy tony's son
beast of a skater riley riley hawk yeah
i had him on my podcast he uh
he actually just i mean obviously he was
in the environment but he just started
kicking ass on his own really yeah
because he didn't want to like he wanted
to skate but he did right off his dad's
couch
like he just took like he just skated
because he liked to skate you know
took him to like a new level or whatever
but
is tony hawk really tall and and isn't
that hard he's tall yeah
i think i think riley yeah his son's
taller than me now what what
where would you place him as an athlete
is that an athletic thing or is that he
does do he talks about that
he's top five top five yeah pioneer yeah
top five yeah
oh yeah but but skating might have been
the only sport where he would have been
that way i don't know not with his work
ethic he's been successful he's a
professional that's that's fine i mean
he's gonna play in the nba or nfl but
right right for his skill set yeah dude
he'll be good whatever it is he's one of
those winners no oh he he's nobody
the 900 he's like lance armstrong yeah
tony tony type of tony hawk nine hundred
but the the stuff that he did like he
was the first guy to do that first ever
nine hundred and you know he was uh
flagrant he wasn't even planning to do
this he didn't wanna do it he failed so
many times
and then the announcer was like let's do
it he's like [ __ ] it let's try it
boom
oh
but he does get it oh my god damn that's
that's oh gee i remember watching this
and now guys do it all the time probably
oh dude yeah yeah that's tony goes well
you know like once you see what someone
can do then these young kids take
another yeah he goes the stuff they're
doing now i can't do god so kids see
that like yeah
that's possible and then they just take
it it's like the guy who ran the mile
like no one could ever break the four
minutes
high schoolers are running four four
minutes and dude it's nuts yeah watch
his son skate uh just best tricks or
what it's just riley hog you're just
skateboarding yeah
his son's insane but they're different
styles his son's a kid
uh street skater these kids would do
this crazy [ __ ]
so he's tall like his pops yeah
jesus christ yeah that's pretty cool
dude
like just you do some crazy [ __ ] right
oh yeah [ __ ] hey yeah it's pretty
cool so he went kind of opposite of his
dad doing street yeah and so what is it
he's a beast man he skates for one of my
favorite skate companies
he's he's dope nice guy too that's cool
wow super nice guy good for him man
yeah it's really cool like anything else
tony hawk was talking about the video
game tony hawk which is you know game
changer and he was like at the time he's
like yeah whatever video game wasn't a
big deal and he said uh
like they were gonna pay him a fee
and then the company came to him because
they realized how big it was gonna be
and he had no idea he had no money at
the time he was you know skating he was
making decent money but not like rich he
said the company who made the game was
like hey so we'll just pay this flat fee
of like 100 grand
and then call it even and he was like
what's going on here he's like no i'll
take percentage of the sales because i'm
gonna bet on myself take percentage of
the sales and then [ __ ]
it blew up
and there was other skate games before
the before tony hawk pro skater so tony
hawk pro skater [ __ ] they said oh he
had all his buddies involved in the game
because like right you put me in you i
put my friends in you had like female
skaters
they all got paid
when he was skateboarding he probably
had zero idea he was ever going to make
money well that's he said he wasn't
doing it for money yeah it's just when
he started making amazing oh [ __ ] here
but when you obsess over one thing and
you're the best at it well you're not
worried about making money that's when
yeah they weren't making anything like
uh laird hamilton like he was gonna surf
no matter what yeah and just became a
total innovator that's a passion yeah
but
riding these massive [ __ ] waves with
different innovations with boards i mean
you know where where the one bring up
laird hamilton when you surf that one
wave and it and it was oh my god on surf
magazine oh it's nuts and if he had
fallen there was a seven story building
i'm sponsored by
by by sir
yeah by surf by uh
all right there i am
now that's
now that would be now that would be in
that would be how huge is that [ __ ]
wave well you can get sucked up into it
yeah and i just saw him at uh irwin
you can tell that he is a very sturdy
human being well when i was built
different bubba when i saw him when i
saw him in his prime when i saw him in
his prime i promise you
i promise you you'd look at him and go
well that guy is gorgeous thicker than
yours he was 235 six foot four and just
is he is now seeing mayor de city
crawford he's not married to crawford
he's married to gabrielle reece
who is a professional volleyball player
and she's every bit of six foot that's
right yeah i worked with her who who's
the guy married to sydney crawford that
would be randy gerber who owns oh he's
not
and all that
i think he's a server but not like this
guy now go go to go to young
if you go to young uh uh larry hamilton
you'll get a load of what he was built
like
i mean he was just
i saw him
years ago well it's just his neck and
that's you and lord hamilton right there
that's definitely as old as you alert
hamilton yes it is when he was younger
now you're spearfishing he's surfing
that would be me that's you right there
that old man dude
you know who that is that's you and blue
in 20 years
yes it is
yes it [ __ ] is that's you and blue in
20 years well i had my dream i had my
tits removed but look at him when he was
a young kid he was a he was just big and
strong
his wife is gorgeous too man yeah oh
look he's just a freak
dude he's built like a stingray look at
his [ __ ] neck yeah he's like brock
lesnar that's when he was saying he's a
tall dude bro yeah six four six four
yeah very big guy
when i when they walked in i remember i
saw him at the firehouse 20 years ago
and i was like who the [ __ ] are these
guys oh dude i'm at irwin you know in
line with my [ __ ] juice and he's in
front of me yeah and right away i'm like
god's [ __ ] little that's how he looks
now
and he had him that's how it's exactly
how he looks now he's built like a brick
[ __ ] [ __ ] crazy now if you look
at him when he's younger when he was
surfing when he was making a name for
himself he was like there right look at
his back right there how old is he
um
yeah right there where he's he's doing
his board yeah yeah like he's just that
is he your age brian he's i think he's
my age yeah such a freak dude just a big
wave rider though one of the first the
ride the guy was riding he does crazy
workouts now at his house yeah
my favorite story my favorite story is
my friends pitbull
is locked onto another pit bull
on the beach
in malibu dog maggie
and my friend's big strong guy but he
didn't know how to he didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do so he's trying to pull
his dog off people are screaming
along comes laird hamilton
who comes running up
grabs both the dogs runs into the water
holds them under the water until they
let go because they're going to drown
goes which one is who's oh my friend's
like that and he goes all right and just
gets of the way and just keeps running
everybody's like that's a [ __ ] see
ladder dude my buddy gavin o'connor who
is that what other direct other big
surfers are around that age there's him
who's the other huge one
uh
all those guys that were together in
writing
i talk to kelly slater all the time you
do right all the time yeah fighting talk
fighting fighting loves fighting
i mean him dm he's the michael jordan of
uh kelly slater's the nicest guy he has
a store in malibu he's the nicest
[ __ ] guy really knows
the best and he knows his [ __ ] about
fighting no he's such a freak out dude
i'll he'll go what he would go talk
about picks like what do you think he'll
pick him this week i'll tell him and
then he'll be like oh i think that i'm
like oh [ __ ] this dude knows his stuff
dude you know what you know what keeps
me up at night what
you know back in the early 2000's
blackberries yeah they were hot i
remember blackberries remember then it's
not sitting in my drawer now it's got
lots of dust stuff yeah bro but you do
back in 2000 that thing was lit oh it
was the thing but how about my boy steve
jobs came along with apple and then you
know what i bet we could make a better
phone and dude and someone said let's
make this a podcast talking about
business wars man there's a podcast you
hear about how blackberries and the
iphone's battled oh so so basically it's
the it's behind the scenes as business
changes the innovation changed and one
industry died the other one won yeah man
on business wars iphones versus
blackberry you'll hear how blackberry
the phone favored by presidents wall
street and a lot of times government
officials yeah iphone was just a better
product dude and the dude then apple
came along they pushed the envelope
capitalism babies oh my gosh it's called
creation
creative destruction fantastic
fantastic iphone wins over blackberry in
this corner listen to the phone listen
to the business wars iphone vs
blackberry podcast on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen ad free
by joining wondering plus in one reap
okay here's the thing about insurance
dude i don't know how to find it i don't
know how to search for dude it's
exhausting
and also i don't know if i'm getting
scammed i don't have time to compare a
bunch of prices dude i'm too lazy shut
your old trap dude that's where the
zebra is panicking dude you need the
zebra you can compare car and home coats
from every major insurance company in
order for five minutes hold on what does
it do dude it's the fastest way to find
the right coverage at the right price
right so it what it it finds all the
different quotes yeah saves you money
one saves money an average of 922 bucks
a year on home and auto combined in
other words they focus on details so you
don't have too many tails save time and
money in minutes compare quotes for free
at the zebra.com fighter that's the
zebra.com fighter
zebra here's the thing dude you know
what when you get tired and i can see
you're tired you need to pick me up
sometimes you might need some alpha
brain you might do i need alpha brain i
swear by it you might need some
digestive health dude you know you know
daddy had a food poison and i used a ton
of total gut health so let's listen to
this i had food poisoning i i was
nauseous for one month i took total gut
health it went away that that happened
for a month that is i really was a long
time well i i would i would eat and i'd
be nauseous eat i don't remember that do
you remember i remember that yeah i took
i took uh literally like total gut
health right yeah and i i swear to god
better me too because they have they
have they really do have scientists and
doctors that look into all of this
if you're taking someone's not on it you
suck how about that on it.com slash
fighter 10 off everything everything
they offer man coffee we also got
fitness gear it's a one-stop shop
protein powder shop we got streaming
fitness on-demand workouts battle rope
steel club mesas kettlebells primal
bells we got all man on it.com fighter
10 off
can i get your picks by the way bring up
bring up the fights this weekend because
i'm going to give you my picks and i
want to get your picks
first of all the big one
uc 269 oh we got to bet on it don't we
yeah let's see where we're different
though because i think i'm up by a
thousand
no remember we're even though are we you
owe me money yeah cause canelo fight
yeah but then i won
i won the peter yan yep but then i want
canelo
nothing we're even yeah i think we're
even
all right so we got so the the main ones
you got charles oliveira dustin poirier
amanda nunes julian pena neil ponce
nabio
cara france cody garbrandt first out 125
for cody garbrandt you got sean o'malley
so i got o'malley
okay yeah everyone does yeah
this is his first like top ten fighter i
think no it's not no i'm not even close
keep going nope no danger
pavilion i'm close top then oh he's not
all right sean o'malley's not writing
they're bringing up very they're
bringing them up very slowly
uh cody garbrandt uh first time at 125.
i don't know what that weight cut is for
him i have no idea so i don't know i
don't know i think he'll be fine because
he's a small 35er all right you you got
your money on kobe 100 percent green
knocks that guy out and france is no
punk
that's a tough fight for him at first
flight of flyweight yeah i don't know
jeff anil or santiago oh man that's a
shame that's a great fight
all right so what do you want to [ __ ]
bet on
uh i'm not betting i mean
amanda is going to wait on that she's
going to win that
main event who you got
this is where i make my money [ __ ] um
now charles oliveira has more ways to
win
he does better striker
better on the ground i would contest
that i would contest he's a better
striker i would actually contest that
emporius heavier handed
deliver technical wise much better
striker i don't know kicking
muay thai
dustin priya's kicks and punches his
boxing is so on point um
i i don't know i i know i i i charles
delivered the most finishes ever when
you see history
well he's got those
i i that's from his back he's got great
guard and all that i don't think that
works on dustin for you okay
[ __ ] it
well yeah now here's the thing dustin's
been through the wars
jose has been through [ __ ] wars he's
been through wars too
oliveira's
early in his career would quit
i'm gonna go with dustin priya yeah me
too you are yeah i was trying to entice
you to take charlotte charles
i think i think dustin's just i think
charles has a million ways to win yeah
but dustin has the power and as it gets
in the fourth and fifth round dustin's
gonna finish him he's gonna clip him
because he has power yeah and dustin's
impossible to finish unless your name
could be he's impossible to finish and
that's right and he's impossible to
finish and you know what you know why
i'm picking dustin he's tougher well
dustin's going to be any is anything
he's not his back i see him on top of a
little and look at the resume of dustin
he's fought everyone and won the
majority of those fights at all he's
seen everything it's just his time too i
feel like yeah
i don't know though i don't know is it
his time is it his time here's the
difficult thing to say he's i believe
he's been through some
even more crazy wars
i mean then then oliver has taken so
much damage
the justin gaichi that iavrez fights
yeah the the hooker fight all that he's
just a beast man
um
he left a piece of himself in there
against max holloway
um
yeah uh max hallway not a power puncher
no came up from 145. god bless max for
that yep
we go to charles oliveira
people forget how long he's been doing
it dude see he's been doing it oh excuse
me sir forever yeah and i didn't i
didn't realize but so he's been the ufc
since 2010 11 years wow i didn't [ __ ]
know that 11 years wow now remember he
lost to max holloway he lost a pettis
who packed it
look at this lost at frankie edgar
lost to max holloway lost to ricardo
llamas now that was a different oliveira
now he's a he's a different animal yeah
oh no slouches he lost her now hey chin
what's the what's the vegas odds what's
draftking's odds on this
if you click on the boost tab bar bren
shop picks you can boost your odds you
got to have uh it's a parley three-man
parlor you got dustin poirier cody
garbrandt tied to avasta to boost your
odds there it is scroll up scroll up
right there
minus 160 plus 140.
so dustin's the slight favorite there oh
that's that's surprising to me me too
more ways to win champion and he's he
just keeps getting he's the intern
champion he's perfect
now when should they just give that belt
to the championship should they just
present to see if monkey gets through uh
uh
yeah he's going to do darius's monster
yeah he's a monster for three in the
world it doesn't matter his wrestling is
is no good here yeah against micah
similar styles of wrestling i think
darius has that [ __ ] greco no [ __ ]
jiu-jitsu black belt i thought he was
also like uh
muay thai really jiu-jitsu what about
his but he he seems to do a lot of that
suplexing and [ __ ] upper body throws
and stuff there's nothing too strong no
his background is just yeah no he's
great but yeah
he's gonna make us
kind of you don't know i've watched
quite a lot i've watched aries fight a
lot see what his background is i feel
like he's jujitsu he's a
world-class jiu-jitsu but also wrestling
wasn't he didn't he do any wrestling
grappling
but i don't think he has like uh
especially compared to mockup
i feel like he did bubba i feel like
he's born right in iran yeah so that was
right so so when you're iranian you come
up under that that wrestling system he
did he's been wrestling no no he hasn't
no he hasn't bob i promise you he has
been doing a lot of wrestling he started
jiu jitsu he began training in jiu jitsu
he earned his black belt in five years
which is insane decorated competitor
became a nogi world champion of the blue
purple and brown belt i understand i
think though and i heard them talking
that he had wrestled he had started as a
wrestler though in iran i believe that's
the that's true does he say that chen
it doesn't say anything of that i'm
almost positive that i heard i i know he
got started in martial arts with jiu
jitsu yeah i'm sure i'm sure but i think
that he came hey
he didn't his background is jujitsu
his specialty is jujitsu yeah
world-class jiu jitsu guy dude
yeah
fell in love with wrestling when you
started college later that year
jiu-jitsu
okay so
i fell in love with wrestling yeah when
he was young in iran when he was
training didn't say that by when he was
trained by it says by khabib's father
wow
so in high school dears played soccer
near the end of a senior he took advice
from a friend trapped for wrestling he
fell in love with wrestling when he
started called lately he signed up
brazilian jiu jitsu
and then just started doing jiu jitsu no
wrestling background he's in my blood
wrestling
this is the thing when we break down
fights yeah you talking about so it's a
little tough i do know what i'm talking
about because you assume
because he's from iran yeah that's like
assuming because he's from brazil he
just does just does jiu-jitsu it's
exactly right or because he's everyone
in because he's korean he
yeah well so anyway he's gonna have his
hands full he's gonna have his hands
full okay he's [ __ ] tough though dude
yeah he's tough dairy's just so [ __ ]
tough striking power definitely an
advantage
submission's definitely an advantage
submissions oh yeah
i don't know what do those guys do those
what are those thoughts
no
i'm telling you but this isn't like hey
what do you think bro i'm telling you
man but as far as submission oh dear
she's better submissions as far as
grappling yeah as far as like their dag
stain wrestling that [ __ ] yeah yeah
dude he's you know you know they're able
to somehow get on top of you and neutral
they control because they control their
hips they control everything [ __ ] they
just break you and then they just rain
elbows nuts so they go you're jiu jitsu
that's all cool it doesn't work here
they just want to hold your hips to the
ground
samba their submission so they they know
the setups it's all transition so
they're just stopping you you didn't
alive dude they either before you're
moving they're not letting you move
you're seven steps ahead of you
even if you know i wanna you know what
i'd be curious though if daryus gets a
hold of his ankle or something like that
like the knee bars and ankles that could
get a little dicey but they're sambos
i would have loved to have seen i feel
like jake shields against one of those
dog the dagestani guys i think he did
roll with those guys back in the day
and what are you curious about i want i
i feel like he was
so dominant as a grappler in general
and you think jake would take down the
destinations
or you think he would submit him from
his back
shut up
here's the thing jake shut up jake's
never been on his back he doesn't
usually get on his back he's good from
the top yeah so how so i love jake yeah
how would jake take him down brian okay
so it's a different game now he might be
i'm just saying he's gonna swim off his
back now well
i guess he wouldn't take i don't think i
don't know if you're taking the doggos
down he's definitely not
you know you know who could do it the
guy who who could [ __ ] with them
especially in his prime tony ferguson
you think so oh yeah not takedowns
off his back very dangerous
elbows those make those that's a
different game yeah tony ferguson's the
monster with elbows off his back his
submissions his guards filthy it's
unique yeah because the eddie bravo
system so it's stuff they're not used to
who
a guy like brian ortega could be a
problem for a guy like khabib who who
held uh somebody took tony ferguson
though and held him on his back and
pounded him with kevin lee
it was also wasn't it also uh our boy um
charles de la verde be the [ __ ] out of
that yeah
but that's you know tony's long in the
tooth man in his primed when when he won
like 10 in a row
when they were trying to make the khabib
fight when it was like prime tony
ferguson dude one of the best 155 is
walking the [ __ ] person 100.
monster [ __ ] monster
terrifying
well we got no bet because we got the
same picks
boy mma doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
huh the minute
they cut kevin wing yeah
that's so disrespectful man is that not
the way to do it i mean that's how i
that's i mean when i retired they sent
me emails said hey i remember that cool
we still own you come back
i know the game it's the game it's pro
sports dude it's it's the game yeah
that's what you signed up for just i
think guys get butt hurt but it's like
it's [ __ ] cut that's that's the
territory also though there is something
about mma that i think is undeniable
something happens you can be so [ __ ]
great and you suffer one loss
and and father time something happens
father time goes it's a bad loss
well like tim kennedy was in many ways
the toughest human being i've ever seen
in my [ __ ] life still is and never
got tired and just was like insane he
basically beat you el romero and then he
fought kevin gaslam and i think at that
point it was like father tom was like
okay we're done now we're done now yeah
he was like oh you look like a different
guy against yeah and to his credit he
was like okay yeah you're like where is
what happened he just wasn't as into it
anymore his head he had other things
going on he was doing other things yeah
like fighting for our freedom that's
correct and you're welcome that's
correct and you're welcome wait how long
was he in the u.s
how about the rock while beating him in
strikeforce oh that was a great fight
[ __ ]
jesus
yeah he's a beast damn dude then gracie
had his back he had hundred gracie's
back
tim's a freak man i love that dude
all right jim what do you got for us
[Music]
so we talked about this in depth for the
past few weeks about china having these
uh protocols in place with social media
and young people where they can only see
like a certain amount of a certain type
of content before they start veering
them off into something more educational
awesome and instagram is actually taking
this into place for people who sign up
under uh like a certain age restriction
so if you're under the age of 18 there
are new uh protocols being put into
place where if you spend too much time
on a certain topic instagram will then
veer you off into something a little
more educational yeah but can't the kids
just put in there they're like 22 when
they sign up for it yeah anyone can do
that
yeah that's right this is just them
protecting their ass yeah and i think a
lot of it is also trying to protect uh
young influencers like a lot of the kids
who came up from tick tock a lot of them
are still minors yeah so you can no
longer tag or dm a minor who is not
following you anymore because
a big issue with young influencers were
like a lot of people like adults were
just funny yeah slide in trying to dm
well i was i was watching the uh
people's choice awards last night and uh
they had like all these celebrities
there then that charlie what's her name
emilia damilio chucci has 50 million
followers on tick tock
i think it's like over 100 million last
night they said 50 million 50 million i
think it's on instagram really yeah
that's what they said on there my buddy
but you but like they're interviewing
your buddies not hurt but the thing is
when they're they're in 127 million
followers think about the power that kid
has 17. but they're interviewing you
know like
the rock all these huge celebrities they
get to her and you know they're they're
getting off everybody's accolades and
they get turned like 127 million
followers and it's like
that's currency now in hollywood
like what skills does this girl have uh
she got popular because she is a dancer
she's a legit dancer right yeah she grew
up dancing because she started posting
uh videos of her dancing on tik tok for
fun and that's how she got
i mean yeah naturally they read all that
[ __ ] that's like the bad [ __ ] 127
million followers let's say one percent
give you hate yeah that's a lot but like
to a kid that'll [ __ ] them up to us i
mean they're millionaires from crimea
river but the thing is is it's just
weird i was watching and it's all these
celebrity like talented actors
127 million followers and like okay i
just think i it's such a weird like the
the dynamics of hollywood is i was just
watching it so [ __ ] well they had they
had what they have the rock there who's
like you know
but there's a whole sub culture now so
all these mobsters that are now getting
out of jail after 20 years 25 years
you know what they're doing they're all
doing podcasts they're they're all doing
they're all they have like youtube
channels and they have huge following
interesting you killed 19 people cool go
away he puts john gotti away yeah man
and then he comes back he's telling
stories people love him dude he's
telling he's one of the best
storytellers i've ever heard he was
telling a story about how they got this
guy john john um doesn't matter yeah
johnny lee johnny lee who was head of
their there was a war going on
one family i think the genovese and
gambinos they couldn't get to him
because he was surrounded by 30 dudes so
he says
so he goes in and he goes tell him i'm a
punk and i want to bring a message from
paul castellano so he goes into this
diner and the guys are knocking them out
of their 30 guys just hey tough guy and
he said look if you go there and you say
that paul wants to meet him they don't
believe you they're going to take you
down in that basement they're going to
torture you yeah and and you know so
it's all this stuff long story short he
gets the guy and this guy johnny johnny
lee who was
like the hitman's hit man and he was he
ran this whole crew and if they killed
him they knew the war would be over
they'd win the war so long story short
he samuel has to pretend he's he's a
total like he said he's just like i
can't get some water i'm so nervous i
just i'm just trying to give you the
message you know i just want to know
exactly this
he wants to meet you somewhere you pick
the spot but he wants to do it alone
they go meet at a country club
uh the country club i belong to great
they got a van waiting he goes i'm going
to walk when i go by the van i'm going
to stutter step i'm going to get like a
couple in spam i'm going to bear hug him
open that [ __ ] door i'm going to pull
him in and then hold him down one more
time drop him up long story short they
get him and the [ __ ] guy's sitting
there and he looks at him he's like this
he goes unbelievable punk huh you're the
you're the messenger boy huh you had me
going you had me going sammy and he goes
hey it is what it is and then he goes
now he had to wait to get a call okay to
kill him and it was going to be
if he hit the side of the van once
he's let him go
twice
i got to kill you oh so now
so these guys are all killers right and
the dude the dude is sitting there like
this and he's remember he has 50 bodies
to hit this guy that he's got and he
goes like this he goes hey jerkoff
and sami goes what he goes
cover the back window he goes what do
you mean he goes
because
there are a bunch of truckers here if
they look in the back window they're
going to see me tied up and they're
going to call the cops i'm not going out
that way you don't want to go out there
cover the back oh wow so sammy the bull
goes what a gangster this [ __ ]
is telling me how to do a hit he goes to
chris
he goes santa ball goes this guy's a
stupid [ __ ] gangster he had a respect
for him yeah now he goes he goes all of
a sudden i'm like what kind of a guy do
i have here yeah and then he goes like
this he goes they start talking and he
goes
he goes uh
he goes sammy do me a favor in my pocket
there's a i got pills you got to put one
under my tongue and the guy goes sami
goes why he goes i got pains in my chest
it's nitroglycerin i don't want to die
by heart attack i'm not going out like
that i look like a [ __ ] put it under my
[ __ ] house so sammy goes and he knows
he breathes
gonna kill him it gets better puts it
under his [ __ ] tongue like that and
and he goes like that now if i don't get
better in five minutes put another one
under my tongue you got me you hear me
listen to me so sammy's like this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] he's crazy yeah then he goes
like this then he goes like this he
looks at me he goes
you're one of us he goes goes nostra and
he goes like this he goes
i can make you a rich man you let me go
you know that right and sammy goes i got
too much respect for you right now don't
do that and he goes i'm not i was just
testing you oh ooh i was just testing
him he goes good no money right not
not all the money worthless not all the
money in world goes good boy
then he goes like this then he goes like
this he gets a boom boom no no he here
they hear walking but nobody's banging
on the truck yeah he goes if it's a cop
shoot that [ __ ]
shoot him
i want to see him die before i go
wow so now he's like what kind of a
[ __ ] do i have here yeah what
kind of [ __ ]
he gets the bang the double yeah
he goes you lost the decision at this
point it's been 13 hours he got him
coffee 13 hours jesus christ so they're
hanging out yeah he goes i love this man
he goes this man embodied everything
about cousin astra that i could ever
think of he goes i fell in love with
this guy and and i didn't [ __ ] him and
he goes like this basically and he goes
like this he gets he goes like this he
goes you lost the decision bro i got to
kill you
and he goes
can you do me a favor and he goes
anything and he goes take my shoes off
when i don't want them find me with my
shoes on he goes why i guess oh i always
told my my wife i'd die with my shoes
off meaning i'd die at home my shoes off
she thought i'd die like a dog in the
street and that's the way it is she
knows this life and i told her and and
sammy goes done done so he takes his
shoes off for him and then they try to
drag him out he goes get your [ __ ]
hands off him get your [ __ ] hands off
him he goes he goes john you want you
want you want to roll out yourself and
he goes yeah let me roll out myself and
he goes he goes and he introduces him he
goes he's one of ours he's a made guy
his name was uh uh ray alito or whatever
yeah ray's gonna be ray's gonna shoot
you he's gonna he's gonna do the killing
so he goes he introduces him like it's
all formal jesus christ and he goes
do me a favor just walk about four four
feet into the
weeds duck your head and he's gonna kill
you just like that and the guy goes all
right
good boy
keep your head out of trouble and just
[ __ ] shut him in the head just took
his took
four steps bent his head boom and then
he shot him three more times they found
him with his shoes off jesus christ bro
he tells these stories but you're just
of course [ __ ] in life
and he talks about getting made he talks
about the the getting paid the whole
ceremony he goes he goes have put on a
white shirt a tie and your best suit and
meet me on this corner now here's the
problem with that
sometimes
yeah sometimes you think you're getting
made and you're never coming back what
exactly it's out of the best day of your
life the worst day of your life exciting
life but never ends well down they go
down to the [ __ ] they go down the
basement paul castellano is there the
head of the gambino crime family and all
the other made guys and they're all
sitting there and he goes you know these
people he goes yeah he goes and legos
you swear this is a secret society we're
causing ultra what finger do you do you
pull the trigger with he points at that
they burn the finger they do some ritual
in italian he says all these italian
words then they all hold hands
and they they do some weird like
i don't know some talk and he goes now
from now on and then they go through a
list of what's what what is constitutes
a death penalty if you raise your hand
to a friend of ours meaning another made
guy you die if you introduce
yourself to somebody else as a maid guy
to somebody who's not you you that's the
definition this is great so you have to
be introduced by somebody else who's
made to somebody else who's made it it's
[ __ ] cookie rules that's cool that is
[ __ ] great dude well you can see how
some guys get the likes
well even the head of uh the guy he was
the youngest uh head of the hells angels
chapter he's 22. wow dude he he was
telling a story again he's he did prison
like eight years he came out doesn't
[ __ ] with it anymore does all this like
again podcasting and like he talks to
businesses and stuff he's like a real
leader that's how he got in that
position yeah smart guy dude he was
talking about
i think i was asking him
what what he got pinched for and he said
i was i was dating this girl and he was
like and she was the love of my life but
he said the hell's angels the lead the
youngest chapter ever like i had ladies
and she didn't want to be there that's
fine he said but meet her stayed very
tight and he goes and then uh her
parents owned the bar that we'd hang out
in she started dating this guy who
started beating her up he's like can
people know me and dude he's ready for
this
he's the leader of the hell's angels
he's six three 290 pounds okay not fat
yeah that's the problem there is guys
he's jacked
him up when he's young he's jacked huge
so he goes and he goes so people knew i
was the head of the area
right
so he goes people knew i was the leader
of the hell's angels and they go they
tell the boyfriend go hey man you know
that's like mel's ex-girl like he finds
out you're [ __ ] he goes oh he's not
gonna do [ __ ]
so he was really close with the parents
he went over like bring him food or
something because he was always really
nice to him goes bring him food she
walks in the door and her orbital's
broken her face is all busted up and he
goes oh hell no are you kidding me
because you got to quit [ __ ] this guy
so uh the next day he calls her to check
in on her he didn't know the boyfriend
was in the car she has him on speaker
and he's like hey just wanna make sure
you're all right the boyfriend goes
don't [ __ ] call i got a bullet with
your name money goes okay okay tough guy
hangs up the phone he tells his two boys
he's like we gotta go over there yeah
they go they they entice him over there
somehow like she like sets him up he
goes over there they're there they walk
out of the back room they tie him up so
first of all he goes well he tried to
fight me and the guy goes how big were
your time he was 63 290. yeah so it
didn't end well for me because then i
can and he goes and i can fight he was
and i can fight so he had his hands full
there he was eventually gifts up we tie
him down and that's when the boys took a
baseball bat to him oh my god yeah well
that look at him look at him
yeah that's why he's [ __ ] yeah that's
a thick kid that that's why you don't
[ __ ] with the hell's angels or a group
of you know
an organization a an organizer the
hell's angel thing's so tempting you
don't get it i know you don't i just
couldn't be i couldn't enforce anything
and they'd force me to like beat guys
out i don't want to do that i can't do
anything if i was like man you have to
pay for my kids shoes i'm like all right
i'll be back next time for us no that's
not i can't live that life the anxiety
at night and [ __ ] for us and he was
talking about that like he was talking
about some of the shooters some of the
guys that used to run the thing it'd be
this tiny skinny little old man and
you're like that guy it was like yeah
that guy yeah he's a social guy he'll
shoot you and kill you it's a big
difference it's so strange that
lifestyle his he's got it's called our
thing it's a podcast uh-huh it's really
nice
they make so much money michael franchez
the same thing michael franklin
what is the podcast what's really
fascinating about it it's called the our
thing
it's [ __ ] good but sammy the bull
because i used to i know i remember him
i remember him i remember back in then
we should get that milk on this podcast
we should get sammy the bull on this
[ __ ] okay because he's in arizona
he's gonna yeah he's got great he's just
shush get bradford yeah he would do it
yeah i bet you'd come on sammy the ball
i bet we get mel the hell's angel guy
i'd love to
that'd be heavy dope their merch is so
lit
yeah
i mean you can't just wear it and don't
be capping
don't copy it don't copy it they'll pay
you a little bit
you told me about a friend copy they got
him on the street yeah he didn't sell it
anymore yeah yeah
dude they're they're remember there's
like lawyers who are hell's angels like
they got it
yeah
and depending on where you're at like if
you're uh if you ride a motorcycle and
you wear a cut it has to be like
approved oh yeah yeah oh yeah apparently
when you held angel's worldwide san
francisco like a lot of them were there
yeah what'd you say brian you and i did
a show in san francisco and apparently i
did one in indianapolis years ago and
they're all in the front row i was
making fun of them because i didn't see
the hell's angel patches and i was
making fun of him saying oh sense of
anarchy rejects it you know
they were laughing no they were laughing
okay but they had the vip meet and greet
they came in like we own the
strip club down the road the the baby
but we're gonna feed the baby birds
remember that yeah and i was like okay
i'll see you there and jay's like we're
not [ __ ] going there
you know i love health angels right yeah
i don't know why yeah that whole thing
michael francis i was talking about and
and one of the things that samuel is
talking about is he learned from his
mentor that violence is always the last
resort like he would be like i don't
know it's gonna send the young guys over
there and beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
he's like no ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha here both sides yeah before
you do that [ __ ] that's all that's how
you get in trouble of course yeah yeah
of course they're not yeah they're not
trying to they're like and the other
thing is michael another business they'd
be successful in anything michael
fantasia who was the maid guy and a
captain did 10 years and he he comes out
and they were saying i heard that such
and such killed uh had over a hundred
bodies and he goes like this he goes
there weren't even a hundred guys there
were 113 guys in the entire family where
are these bodies yeah when people say
that they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about five people
five people have a shitload of people
yeah five you're a serial killer yeah
five years old
to if you're a mafia guy and you killed
if you did work as they call it that's a
lot of people yeah what else you got jen
here so i saw this clip on barstool of
uh a college basketball player from
tennessee trying to make
a score and
win the game but it goes terribly wrong
so he had him on a treadmill he ate all
his food while he was on the treadmill
what what
yeah
he he got so roasted i bet yeah he got
roasted again what happened did he
[Applause]
you know it's nice you have a short
circuit yeah
uh did it say something happened to him
like did he hurt his leg nothing was
wrong with him nothing was wrong with it
it looks like something happened right
it looks like he pulled something yeah
he was like oh [ __ ] jimmy burke told me
about his buddy he's a good athlete and
they're getting a fight they're on the
softball you're in the softball they're
playing softball in [ __ ] central park
and uh his buddy harry gets in a fight
and i guess harry kind of
he's this big guy he went to punch the
guy and he went like this he went he he
was awkward and he was like
and he he
ah and he just kind of threw his wrist
and like that
and in the middle of fighting somebody
was like what kind of punch is that you
[ __ ] idiot
you know you can have a short circuit
the wrong yeah it's not a good [ __ ]
yeah a little muscle spasm maybe
you know what i
mean okay we got to do it the other day
yeah
we had a lot of dabs
so cnn news anchor
uh what's his name
don lemon was recently accused by jessie
smoley while he was on trial that uh don
lemon gave jesse the heads up hey police
officers before chicago yeah before the
trial but the trial they were
investigating it yeah the trial just
happened jesse had a friend
police department goes hey just what you
know they're not buying your story yeah
yeah which is interesting i wonder if
cnn's gonna do anything so sometimes a
journalist though wants the story so
they'll chum up to the guy no no no
they're friends they're friends previous
okay yeah thanks because jesse uh had
talked about this on this example i
believe yesterday but is that bad i'm
not a huge fan of don lemon but is that
bad
i mean according they all suck
cnn and their people yes
you know what he's doing now right what
he's doubling down and saying he's so
[ __ ] do you see the the cross
prosecution no they
lit him up
destroyed him
he's like by the way no i they lured me
they said to come get well he's still
saying yeah he said they lowered yeah
but the cross prosecution went through
his dms where they so they did a
rehearsal before so when he was like he
was at random act they have all the dm's
lining it up he's dying on this hill but
then those you know the two brothers the
swollen yeah
because they went against him he just
threw them by the best he's like well me
and that one jacked off together and
he's like i'm not gay he's like [ __ ]
i mean that guy jacked up together
yeah apparently jesse was really
frustrated when he was on the stand to
the point where he started to uh tell
the lawyer like oh you don't even know
anything about instagram when they were
bringing up his dms with the brothers
he's like you don't even know how that
works he's just getting really he's real
hostile makes him look silly
this is this is [ __ ] insane this is a
true narcissist who thinks he can get
away with anything it's just so weird
man that's [ __ ] what's weird is he he
he was he wanted to get more notoriety
for the show did you see how much he was
getting paid how much 18 episodes he's
making like i think it was a big last
season it was 18 episodes he's making
like uh
i think we're like 120 grand an episode
18 episodes yeah that's really good does
he ever work again no no no no no no no
one [ __ ] with him okay
what are we doing
so what's he do a guy like this
i mean i mean like you know the off off
broadway oh okay
i think reality show he'd probably do a
reality i think i think yeah
five years ten years it'll go away i
don't think he's talented enough yeah if
he's more talented i think he'd be all
right but it is so weird man his whole
family he had something awesome it's his
sister killer yeah
yeah
if he had said something to the effect
yeah you know what i did it i hate trump
that much that i did it and i stand by
it hollywood support them yeah people
just hold up just all of that you were
trying to you were trying to [ __ ] them
that that's you you were trying to go it
was an act it's the lying yeah it's it's
better to just own up to be like hey
that's what the [ __ ] i did wow it was
weird though when they were reading the
dms and he says the n-word and dms and
the white prosecutors said the n-word
yep jesse said can you not say that word
he's like sorry i have to spell it out
the white prosecutor said what are you
doing dude no don't say the end i know
what
it's just he's just helping smell it out
yeah that's dumb he's [ __ ] though by
[ __ ] i mean he's gonna get
probation and it just squares [ __ ]
he's not gonna do yeah like he's not
gonna he's not he might have that's not
time but that's not i don't really it's
it's
like maybe like six months it's
disorderly conduct for making the cops
go through all this it's a felony yeah
felony that line in the uh yeah so but i
guess he yeah he probably won't do time
i don't think so but it's just that
public shame yeah i mean she's like [ __ ]
and that's crazy he's dying on that hill
though it's hilarious then he's like man
you're gay
the guy was like what the [ __ ] no
yeah we jacked each other up in that
bath house he's like
when your parents say tell the truth man
that's probably the best advice they
could ever get oh yeah you start lying
you got to remember your [ __ ] lies
yep you got to remember your lies you
got to remember well this one's tough
when you're the only one lying the other
two are in cahoots with you are like
dumb he's so stupid he's also just dumb
it just shows his lack of intelligence
doubling down
poor guy yeah because chicago
prosecutors haven't seen this before i
mean it still goes up to a jury but a
jury is going to be like i mean like you
said yeah you said the cops like
immediately like once they they were
like they know real [ __ ] yeah
off the bat the cops were like in
chicago and they said he left the noose
on his neck when they came to the house
like we have the new son and then he
said a friend of him told him to leave
it on
anybody who went through this traumatic
thing is not going to leave a noose
around there now yeah
hours just walking around yeah
that i saw a picture of it i was like oh
my god
my favorite is the note that he wrote
yeah was the thing that's so hilarious
the fact that he put mega on it
people are crazy do you guys remember
the original story he said that happened
too he said he was on his way to
somebody so in the middle of the night
like 1am in chicago during a polar
vortex
that's right and that's where it
happened and remember he brought the
sandwich back to his apartment after the
struggle after the fight he actually had
the sandwich
see cops are just those cops are just so
used to that they're like hold on let me
put let's just do a little paintbrush
the cops are like you still got a full
foot long meatball huh yeah they made it
all the way here you got the new shirt
on your neck okay did you put it down
while you're being attacked yeah
yeah and then jesse was like i don't say
white cause that's not fair they were
pale skinned
yeah well those yeah those brothers
i wouldn't use pale skin as a i'd use
any other any other one any other
adjective any other describe than them
that's right any other description what
else you got jen
so a tick tock of sam smith and his
friends on a night out is going viral
because i guess this girl right here is
a fan and she saw sam smith walking by
with a group of his friends she decided
to run out from the restaurant she was
eating in to say hi and tell him that
she's a big fan when she runs out she's
already recording and she says sam smith
i love you and one of his friends says
shut up you bum [ __ ] and tries to knock
her phone down
which then she is stunned by this
interaction like wait i just wanted to
tell him i love him in a different video
she then posted as a follow-up it seems
like sam smith is in the background
saying shut up to her while she's
telling him like no don't tell me to
shut up i love you oh wow so he's
getting a lot of backlash online for
this
also she's like running up i mean
why do you gotta record this yeah come
on shut the [ __ ] up you bum [ __ ] hey
thank you did you off what the [ __ ]
thank god thank you
what the should [ __ ] i just might say hi
she's still in her mouth
yeah she's got food in her mouth she
looks annoying too but like also like
running up like this so that is kind of
obnoxious
don't tell me to show up i love you
but also how do you know he's saying
shut up did it sound like he was saying
they're speculating that it's him but
you can't really see those words
yeah the [ __ ] guy's walking and some
crazy person comes up and so someone one
of his friends might have been drunk
yeah he was joking around shut up you
dumb bum i don't know also
i don't know he's at a pub with his
friends yeah
she's doing that selfie thing with him
that's that is so important yeah when
you're just like you know yo
yeah like what were you you're making it
about yourself what's the plan then yeah
yeah she seems like a nice gal but i
mean no she's annoying yeah she's not
yeah she's she's like
leaking yeah super icing off of it
because she started doing tick-tock
trends afterwards like exactly yeah
right
to get
followers oh yeah
all right
forget that girl give us one more change
it's a good one let me see here um
there's not really that oh this is
actually kind of cool this vegas
restaurant is giving a dinner away as
well as a rolex watch
and i don't know if you know this
particular model but it's uh
rolex gmt master ii yeah sick batman so
it's black and blue yeah can i see a
picture i did pull it up before yeah
i mean i saw different ones that are
even more expensive right there type no
type in uh batman gmt i did
uh two-tone yeah and it brought in the
no it's blue and black
there it is right there that one that's
it that's sweet as [ __ ] how much is that
well there's one here there's 99 000.
now that one has uh yeah
no listen anybody puts diamonds on a
rolex a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they lose
value i believe do they they do yeah bro
why because rolex doesn't add why is
that but diamond bizarre how much is
that used
uh not cheap
no that's that's probably used right
there 20 grand probably used right there
brand new i mean 40 something what's
what's the top notch of the rolex
uh
some of the daytonas are probably the
most expensive those are okay those are
the high ends
somebody yeah they're like 100 grand
right there on this oh yeah
oh look at that black one
i like you know what i like the only
watch i would like i'd wear that mars
odd mars pj yeah with the uh
rubber like yeah those are cool those
are fun how much are those
not cheap
[ __ ] man really they are very expensive
right yeah the royal oaks the big boy
one that that one right 60 grand i won
the royal oak i like that 25 grand
that's not for you
this one's only 59.
[ __ ] the royal oaks
yeah they're great yeah
schultzy has one oh he does mm-hmm
that's a dope i think he has the old
metal one though
you got a new watch run do you have a
new watch yeah i haven't seen them
before no i've had this for years black
one yeah what is that uh brettling oh
sweet i love that one we're a lot of
friends dope that's what i want to get
yeah yeah excuse me watches oh yeah
what's that
this is a brettling yeah with the black
diamonds is that expensive that's got
black diamonds
i don't i mean what's for watch i don't
know what's expensive over 20 no okay
half of that that's exciting oh okay i
mean let's do it
i can't wear my rolex on stage because
it the class when i bend will pop off
you have a cold roller so yeah so i wear
this because i need a band but you don't
that doesn't get that doesn't sing to
you no i love those i wouldn't pay 60
grand i know it's just so expensive yeah
that's a [ __ ] lot i'm just trying to
get robbed and [ __ ] exactly
especially nowadays
nowadays yeah [ __ ] oh i don't wear my
rolex outside of calabasas no
i mean even in calabasas people getting
robbed not really all right what is this
this is just a quick lasso doll
knock on wood what's that um so just get
wrapped in calabasas you just got no
encino
how dare you
nope you're off unless you got do so
this plumber found
he was working on a toilet inside
that guy olsteen's church
and then
and then uh the toilet was he saw like
loose tiles so he pulled it out and
there's a bunch of envelopes there and
those six hundred thousand dollars worth
of cash so i guess someone broke into
this church bank and had that took out
the six hundred thousand dollars and hid
it there so then the the plumber that
found it just returned it all
then months later they gave him twenty
thousand dollars as a reward six hundred
grand i know but still that's 20 rounds
20 000 and they give 20k to like another
foundation charity as well i [ __ ] get
that money and i go buy all those
watches and then i turn around
they probably would have caught homie if
he would have
actually kept that one
they wouldn't have caught him that guy
has some money
yeah those guys are super rich oh yeah
he sells out like staples 10 times over
yeah
oh yeah
he's a good speaker
[Music]
really being mean to him right yeah
they're like you know your piece of [ __ ]
right and he's just smiling yeah oh yeah
john goodman lost a lot of weight holy
[ __ ] where
right there oh [ __ ] i like him fat
200 pound weight loss
good pretty good for his health yeah it
doesn't look good for him it doesn't
look good though his face now is all
drawn up
i mean he's older too
all right brian too no i know but he
does look healthier there doesn't he
yeah he looks funny i like him anyway it
looks healthier
yeah yeah skin never tightens
all right is that it dude that's it
that's it all right kids uh new date
just announced brian kellen will be
there and chappelle and special guest
it's brendan shop and friends at the
melrose improv hollywood improv off
melrose that's in la december 22nd one
show only at 8pm
at the improv in hollywood one show only
sprint job and friends and then uh dania
florida that is fort lauderdale florida
december 30th through january 1st
uh bringing the new year with your fake
friend and then uh how do you say it bee
uh
raleigh not rally raleigh
it's raleigh north carolina january 6
through january 8th then charlotte north
carolina is january 20th through the
22nd that's it kids we got some new
thick boy christmas gear dropping next
week for those holiday gifts bubba berry
bear love you guys what do you got
chapelle uh brian callan's up there
sorry no
uh
the kid is gonna be ahead live at the
six chow house uh with sam tripoli
december 15th that's right uh we got two
shows that's a wednesday december 15th
at six the six chow house in ventura
california get your [ __ ] tickets
they're going fast and we will have a
special guest
i'm not going to say who it is now uh
orlando florida no i'm already there uh
where else am i
kansas city missouri improv december 17
18 19 get yo tickets oklahoma city
oklahoma bricktown comedy club i'm
ringing in the new year with dove
davidoff one of the best to ever [ __ ]
do it and then salt lake city utah wise
guys january 6th through the 8th and the
buttery bros have expressed interest in
coming oh they're going to be there yeah
they'll be there for sure and then uh
maybe you you didn't type in my website
i appreciate it no it's all good
no i'm just kidding you're good uh
as soon as chin pulls it up i think i
don't so yeah i'll be on the road with
brendan uh that first month of the year
in january and then in february february
25th through the 26th i'll be at the
comedy club of kansas city uh other than
that uh go ahead and you know purchase
my merch the love is tight new merch
still waiting for our merch over here
all right i got you you want the yellow
tea dude and then i'll get you to you
know see what size xl you know what uh
and then uh also continue to support my
podcast chappelle's world
episodes every every thursday 3 p.m all
right kids love you bye see you next
time